viens nous allons passer à une autre
distraction la télévision via du japon
nous via la télévision en boîte ou plus
précisément tout de même en mini
cassette achèteront nous un jour en
france des programmes de divisions comme
on achète actuellement indice bien sûr
et toutes les firmes européennes
américaines il travaille meurt donc vous
présenter la solution japonaise
il s'agit en fait de transformer le
téléviseur en lecteur d'image la source
l'image pouvant être aussi bien une
station comme le rtf que des satellites
que des bandes que vous avez chez vous
alors voilà comment peut se présenter un
tel appareil et il s'agit ici au fond de
la transposition vidéo de la mini
cassette que vous connaissez bien pour
le magnétophone et d'ailleurs il n'y a à
l'heure actuelle des conversations pour
que dans l'avenir le système cassettes
et la personne qui a choisi son
programme permis dans sa télé texte si
vous voulez et qui maintenant pas la
mettre en place mais la platine est
extrêmement simple et il y à des
conversations avec des constructeurs
européens clipser d'autres pour
standardiser à l'échelle mondiale
normaliser cette cassette comme
normalité le disque
non ce sera diffusé au japon au mieux
dans un an et donc encore beaucoup plus
tard en france du moins pour cette
marque et aux scop individuel c est bien
cet appareil est annoncée à 2200 francs
ce n'est pas très cher vous allez voir
d'abord il permet de voir en couleurs
vous allez voir qu'il permet de revenir
en arc est aussi sujet lorsque vous
l'aurez vu deux ou trois fois même s'il
vous plaît beaucoup ça vous suffira
alors est-ce qu'il y aura une sorte de
devise est on pense qu'il y aura des
sortes de systèmes d'abonnement
effectivement voyez le retour en arrière
là qui va se faire sans problème
et oui il suffit de changer la prise
d'antenne et éventuellement peut
enregistrer ces quelques a par exemple
l'intention de regarder le journal
il sait qui passe à 13 heures il peut
très bien organisée de telle sorte à ce
que de façon à ce que cet enregistrement
se fasse automatiquement pendant son
absence si bien qu'en rentrant dans la
journée ou en fin d'après midi
il peut très bien vous enregistrer il
joue au regard des télés midi à 15
heures effectivement mais c'est un autre
appareil qu'on conçoit actuellement et
qui permet ça disons tout même qui a
aussi beaucoup de technique là c'est
donc une technique de bandes magnétiques
on étudie des techniques deux fils des
techniques de la graphie ce qui est
certain c'est que c'est la grande
révolution qui se prépare et la personne
a changé très naturellement de son
programme elle avait le choix comment
elles soient parmi les disques très bien
je remercie
cl
j'ai déjoué connaît quelques difficultés
et nous l'avons vu hier avec la
fermeture de l'entreprise gg celui du
jeu de société en revanche est loin
d'être saturé une famille sur deux ne
possède toujours pas de jeu de ce type à
la maison
un nouveau venu cette année qui marche
très fort le jeu vidéo
les trois-quarts vendus en france sont
importés d'extrême orient et surtout des
usa mais les européens entre à grands
pas dans le marché un fabricant propose
même des téléviseurs avec jeux
électroniques incorporels
petit frère du flipper et autres
machines à sous qui ne se rencontrent a
guère que dans les cafés les jeux vidéo
font leur entrée dans les salles de
séjour même plus besoin de mettre un
frein dans la fente ont lu machine jouer
chez soi sont intégrés ou couplé avec le
téléviseur pour 300 francs environ les
prix ont beaucoup baissé
le petit écran se transforme en terrain
de football ou en court de tennis
les adversaires se renvoyant la balle
grâce à une commande manuelle
alors fini le rôle de la télévision à
sens unique de l'émetteur vers le
récepteur sans doute d'autant que les
innovations techniques n'en sont qu'à
leurs débuts dans quelques années voit
deux ans nous aurons des jeux que tout
le monde pourra avoir qui sont déjà
intellectuelle qui seront des jeux type
de bataille navale jeu de dames jeu
d'échecs le coran jouer contre la
machine et nous pourrons utiliser le
petit ordinateur de ménage pour faire sa
comptabilité personnelle pour organiser
ses vacances
parallèlement au marché des jeux vidéo
celui des jeux de société classique et
moins classique connaît lui aussi un
réel succès des dizaines de nouveaux
titres paraissent chaque année des
magasins se spécialisent signe
particulier la plupart des jeux actuels
sont conçus à la fois pour les enfants
et pour les adultes même nathan surtout
connu pour ses jeux éducatifs se plie à
tendance
le jeu c'est une façon de communiquer
les enfants communiquent par le jeu et
je crois que les adultes aussi que lille
par le jeu je dirais même que les
couples peuvent comme ni par le jeu et
créer toute une ambiance en général
sympathique se roule disparaît avec
l'électronique lorsque le joueur tente
de vaincre un ordinateur exemple cet
échiquier qui coûte deux mille neuf cent
fois moins onéreux le jeu de stratégie
avec arrière-goût de maths modernes ils
plaisent davantage aux parents et les
nombreux descendants du monopoly lui
même né en 1929 au lieu d'accumuler une
fortune immobilière
on achète maintenant un continent où du
pétrole je crois pour les adultes
l'argent ne n'intervient pas c'est
plutôt les enfants jeunes qui ce que ça
amuse et cv c'est une façon de certains
ça l'esprit de compétition l'argent
c'est pas vraiment l'argent tout le
monde est bien conscient choix que il
faut pas non plus penser que parce qu'on
joue à l'argent on va être impressionné
lourdement
autre tendance les jeux anciens qui font
peau neuve comme les dames où le jeu de
l'oie et ceux qui sont guedj et yves la
bataille navale électronique en est un
bel exemple quand on sait qu'une simple
feuille de papier et un crayon
permettent des parties exaltante et puis
la sophistication ne plaît pas à tous
le salon du cycle hub de l'informatique
de la communication et de l'organisation
de bureau a ouvert ses portes
aujourd'hui au public au palais du cnit
de la défense caractéristiques
essentielles de ce salon l'informatique
qui fait son entrée à tous les niveaux
dans la nouvelle organisation des
bureaux à ce salon du sicom on discerne
trois tendances principales premièrement
c'est la venue à maturité de
l'informatique mise à la disposition des
petites et moyennes entreprises est
aussi à la disposition de la famille
la deuxième tendance c'est le souci que
l'on a eus qui se reflète ici
d'agrémenter la vie de bureau et le
troisième la troisième tendance est de
mettre à la disposition de la famille
pas seulement de la ménagère
l'informatique les ressources de
l'informel l'ordinateur est sorti de ses
salles réfrigérées viraient même
réfrigérante il a maintenant le
rencontre partout notamment dans les
guichets et le public est en contact
direct maintenant avec les informations
ce qui n'existait pas avant grâce à ces
écrans grâce à ses possibilités de
télécommunications dans l'ordinateur va
partout et ça c'est vraiment la grande
tendance actuelle de notre profession
vous êtes en ce moment devant l'ensemble
am 1,4975 qui est la machine la plus
rapide du monde au point de vue
reproductions de documents
il vous suffit de présenter vos paquets
d'originaux sur la tête de lecture et
l'ensemble est entièrement automatique
c'est à dire que votre ensemble va
fonctionner tête après t'être mais par
contre le papier lui va défiler en
continu ce qui vous permet d'avoir une
production de 18 mille copies heures
très prochainement on trouvera
des foyers où l'appareil de télévision
soit utilisé par exemple pour faire des
calculs et ce sera distribué par les ptt
d'ailleurs il présente un appareil qui
s'appelle tictacs et qui permet
d'utiliser la console de votre appareil
de télévision pour avoir des
informations et peuvent s'en servir
comme d'un organe de calcul
d'ailleurs en plus de tictacs bientôt il
y aura antiope qui permet d'interroger
un ordinateur central pour toutes sortes
de ranger ses salons je crois que c'est
la grande tendance télécommunications
facilité d'utilisation à cause des
microprocesseurs qui font que maintenant
l'ordinateur était à la portée de tout
le monde via même maintenant des gens
qui se fabriquent leur petit ordinateur
sur la table depuis cité ça en fait des
ordinateurs en kit et n'importe qui avec
un microprocesseur peut traiter une
information et l'utiliser par exemple
pour se réveiller ou pour au contraire
mettre la musique à un moment déterminé
dans la vie courante
voilà je crois encore des tendances que
vous verrez ici dans cette manifestation
maintenant reparlons de l'ordinateur qui
décidément est bien sorti de sa
préhistoire et commence son entrée dans
l'âge d'or
au début on s'en est méfié quand même
quand il a remplacé des armes et
d'employés de bureau ou
d'administrations et puis on a fini par
s'habituer à cette révolution
ça ne nous étonne plus en fait de
recevoir nos factures nos feuilles de
paie nos relevés de compte nous
contraventions et j'en passe et des
meilleurs établi par des machines
et pourtant il paraît que nous n'avons
encore rien vu récemment le rapport de
messieurs nora et minc nous l'annoncer
aujourd'hui un symposium comme on dit
organisé par la fondation bull se réunit
au palais des congrès à paris pour
étudier tous les changements tous les
bouleversements même qui peuvent naître
des progrès de l'informatique
ordinateurs domestiques machine à
soigner ou à enseigner machine à
communiquer les exemples ne manquent pas
de ces innovations qui pourraient
changer notre vie françois de closets
nous présente une de ses possibilités de
l'avenir la monnaie électronique exemple
d'innovation informatique la carte
mémoire la mémoire vous le voyez c'est
ce petit circuit intégré qui pourrait
servir de monnaie électronique dans
l'avenir pourquoi
et bien parce qu'au début du mois votre
banque vous remettrez 7,4 avec par
exemple un crédit de 2000 france alors
vous voulez payer un achat au lieu de
trouver dans le magasin un tiroir caisse
vous trouvez cette petite calculatrice
alors bien sûr vous introduisez
immédiatement la carte ou tapez votre
numéro d'identification trouver
quelqu'un avoue l'appareil donne son
accord et en même temps commun qu'ils
vous restent 1930 crédit vous tapez le
montant de votre achat 1 100 francs
aredor bien alors monsieur moreno c'est
vous qui atteint le père de cette carte
mémoire que fait le commerce a en ce
moment là les commerçants voient
apparaître le montant de cette dépense
sur son écran de contrôle et donne son
accord
bien sûr un bouton alors suivant les
instructions je donne mon accord aussi
et maintenant la machine des beats ma
carte de 100 francs
et elle va accréditer le commerçant
quand cela c'est ça c'est à dire qu'une
commerçants disposent d'une carte sur
laquelle cet enregistrement est
effectuée à la fin de la transaction et
d'autre part l'appareil ne donne une
fiche et sur cette fiche vous le voyez
il ya toute la transaction le numéro 2
d'identification bancaire le montant de
ma carte avant la transaction
le montant de ma carte après et puis
toutes ces transactions sont donc
inscrits sur cette carte du commerçant
alors à la fin de la semaine
il va porter sa à la banque l'ordinateur
de la banque va lire ce qui s'est passé
comme opérations sur cette carte
et puis il fera toutes les transactions
sans chèque certes dès aujourd'hui la
banque 10 massivement l'informatique
témoins ces ordinateurs qui avale et
niger de milkshake qu'à la minute mais
il ya tout un autre aspect qui n'est pas
encore dans l'informatique par exemple
ici on va classer ces chèques de façon
très classique et puis wire va emporter
ses tas de chèques à la chambre de
compensation comme on dit ou entre
banques on va échanger tout ça alors
dans l'avenir que ce soit par la
technique de la carte mémoire carte
haute
tout ça pour espère électroniquement
vous imaginez et le bouleversement pour
la banque mène pour l'organisation de la
profession pour les travailleurs de la
banque
et puis pour les clients aussi tous les
bouleversements que cela pourrait
entraîner
or j'ai pris l'exemple de la banque mais
c'est la même chose pour l'enseignement
de la même chose pour la médecine pour
administration dans tous ces domaines
les développements de l'informatique
dans dix ans dans 20 ans peuvent
bouleverser la vie n'est que temps bien
sûr d'y réfléchir
à l'avant c'est pourquoi des réunions
celle organisée par la fondation bull
sont importants
depuis 18 mois environ on voit en france
des hommes et des dames aussi bien
qu'ils ont sur les oreilles un casque
leur permettant d'écouter la musique
même dans les bruits de la circulation
ce sont des routes mènent l'invention
est dû au président d'une grande firme
japonaise d'appareils audiovisuels qui
désirait lui écouter de la musique tout
en jouant au golf
vous avez sûrement croisé au détour
d'une rue un de ses personnages bizarres
coiffé d'un drôle de casse rappelez vous
il ne manquait que les antennes pour
évoquer une autre planète
mais n'ayez pas peur ils ont simplement
un groupe man beaucoup de gens qui me
regardent avec avec un air une nouvelle
génération du 20e siècle
ça les étonne un peu de voir le walkman
mais moi je m'en fous éperdument oui je
suis bien c'est le principal
pour les connaisseurs le lecteur de
cassettes stéréophonie est devenu
l'indispensable signe d'appartenance à
une certaine caste
l'image de marque ils véhiculent et
celle de l'action de la jeunesse et du
dynamisme
ils ont la sensation de pouvoir se
dégager de tout ce qui est autour de soi
pouvoir écouter la musique
s'extérioriser en soi même être bien moi
j'utilise souvent quand je travaille
dans l'invention qui enchante surtout
les vendeurs 1 millions d'appareils
vendus en france depuis un oignon sont
pris entre 800 et 1200 francs
le walkman dans le métro parce que ça
représente c'est important parce que tu
vas tu vois là c'est triste mais trop
les gens
or la musique durable sur
jazz rock aussi du talent ça détend
c'est vraiment très important
c'est une façon de se couper du monde
quoi c'est une façon se couper du monde
je crois tout aussi
j'aime bien la musique bon j'écoute ce
que j'aime puisque j'ai cassé que
j'enregistre schieber une mode
oui mais une mode peut être pas sans
conséquences il ne s'agit pas d' éviter
aux autres le bruit que l'on peut faire
mais de s'éviter à soit le bruit et la
présence des autres
pour les psychiatres c'est une nouvelle
rupture plus grave que celle des
générations alors ce danseur ou walkman
fait-il un pas en arrière ou un pas en
avant